your family Being Framed by politicians
by intelligence agencies for being
Traders and spies is the most it's it's
it's bigger than Watergate it's it's
insane like significantly and when you
look at the amount of people that were
involved the resources that took place
to create this thing the level of people
Tim that knew uh and we're all in on it
and we're just just fine with that I
mean it's not just you know Comey is the
director of the CIA but Obama knew and
Biden new and Hillary knew and everyone
knew and it didn't matter yeah well
that's the Anna Paulina stuff's
incredible because like yeah Adam Schiff
I remember this just and I take it
pretty personally because I was the guy
that they said I'm gonna go to jail for
life they were going to try me for
treason also a crime punishable by death
you know Minor Details for me at this
point it's just another Tuesday but you
know that guy was on TV every day saying
he had seen the evidence he had it I was
going to jail for life and you're
sitting there being like I don't even
understand what's going on and like let
alone uh that this is happening but they
could do that